hello reject nation my name is sally
lamonico and i am doing videos on this
channel again uh if you're new here hi
you can call me salamander if you want
to i do have an instagram sally lamonico
and a youtube channel of myself so you
can go ahead and go and subscribe to
that but the more important channel
right now is the real rejects because we
are doing a marvel movie marathon i am
so excited i am still on phase one this
is the second video in the series i am
watching the incredible hulk for the
first time i've never seen it surprise
me uh the only thing i do know about the
incredible hulk is that there's a roller
coaster in orlando at universal's
islands of adventure marvel superhero
island that was a mouthful it's freaking
dope and i've been on it many times it's
amazing i just went there actually and
if you'd like a tour of it i have a
video on my channel about it and
hopefully by the time this video comes
out it's on there go ahead and click
subscribe on this channel this is a
series so if you want to keep up with my
movie reactions for the marvel cinematic
universe please hit that notification
bell and you'll be notified when i'm
posting next and you'll also be notified
when greg and john put up their trailer
reactions and reviews and movie reviews
and just everything if you love cinema
please subscribe to this channel because
we will love you
that sounded weird um also you know go
ahead and hit a like and you want to
know why because i spent a really long
time working on my eyeshadow
i mean look at it it's incredible
like
the incredible hulk
so um also if you would like to see a
full reaction aka you can sit and watch
the whole entire movie with me so you
can go to patreon.com there rejects
become a patron of the real rejects and
you can watch the full movie with me
and it's a good time and lastly thanks
to prepper for editing together all of
the highlights for this video i am
incredibly
happy for that thank you guys anyway
let the marvel movie marathon
commence
[Music]
wait wait wait wait i thought i thought
it was mark ruffalo
where's mark ruffalo
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
green sasquatch
i thought he'd have green eyes
[Music]
oh jeez
i'm triggered
jeez what is this high school bro like
for real
better not be any vampires around
oh
that's lucky
okay
it's like a really rich
[Music]
oh no
that looks like paint guys
come on
[Music]
ew
oh my god
is that supposed to be like
a cure for him or something
[Music]
here's something a bit more
interesting it's a possible gamma
sickness
milwaukee
stan
the man drank one of those guarana sodas
guess it had a little more kick than he
was no stan no
target's on the move
don't kill the dog
i hope he dies
she's like wait where are you going
why is he wearing a red hoodie like that
just stands out so stupid
[Music]
you're out
oh
excuse you
those aren't
birds you could have walked
how rude
[Music]
this feels like a horror movie
yikes
he just casually walks away
yeah like that's gonna do anything
i love how bullets are like mosquitoes
to him he's just like ugh get away
i threw up a forklift truck like it was
a softball
well it's gone
well if bannon knows what it is okay
they don't know it's him i
was ben
you have to explain
that statement
that was the most honest
reaction like
you have to explain like i would have
been like yeah you need to explain a
little more
why doesn't the military just use him
i guess he doesn't want to be used but
oh you did not just do that
who would write that
thank you jesus
he thought he was working on radiation
resistance i would never have told him
what the project really was
but he was so sure of what he was on to
that he tested it on himself
and something
just like the green goblin
right
she's alive
[Music]
she moved on bro
what can they do to help you
i could use a bed for a few nights well
you can have the spare room upstairs
that'd be so great
there's um
there's one other thing
sorry i don't know why that made me
laugh
[Music]
there's
i felt that
why don't you just say hi what's your
freaking deal
you're gonna torture this poor girl
again
i would have honked and scared the [ __ ]
out of him
again with the heels on the grates what
is this
there's no way your heels wouldn't go
through oh you saw you saw it you saw it
her heel went through
go with her and of course she's wearing
a white shirt in the rain guys
written by a dude
first sign of any side effect we stop
and you're off team until you straighten
out you'll get two separate infusions
one into the deep muscle
one under the bone marrow
i don't want to see that just cut away
thank you
i hated that noise
what they're here
ready look at me look at me you have to
go far away from me as you can don't
argue with me just go go
oh
stop
girl
what
you can't see this
he's gonna have to [ __ ] out the usb
hit her back here
oh good shot man
get her in the tank
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
get her and why
is she still out in the open like that
like
you're her dad get her to safety
move him toward the cannons
oh my god
[Applause]
stop shooting him it doesn't do anything
it's just gonna ricochet and hit you in
the head
is that all you got
sorry
he just kicks him oh god damn it
dude get away
this is stressful
this is so stupid
um
get her out of the fumes oh my god this
is so this is
making me mad
i'm gonna turn to the hulk right now
you did the right thing calling
i need to know where they're going
should be an incredible danger as long
as she's with me from who
he protected her
you almost killed her
it's a point of professional pride with
me that i can always tell when
somebody's lying
then you are facts facts
i know she'll help him if she can and
she's aiding a fugitive
and i can't help by anyone again her
father's a sociopath
so as the hulk i guess he can still
be caring
it's got a heart like a machine
never seen anything like it outside of a
racehorse
his villain origin story
further search for the mysterious hulk
was postponed by powerful thunderstorms
in the smoky mountain national forest
wait is ho
it's hulk a word hulk means a large boat
so this dude just saw everything it was
like that's a hulk i'm
i'm confused
i can't get too excited
not even a little excited
okay
so if he ever gets horny he turns into
the whole
imagine
[Music]
there's a lot to
explore with them
talking about it but what
the aliases mr green and mr blue have
been added to the shield operations
database
if he comes up for air we'll be waiting
yeah i'm not gonna use credit cards but
i'm gonna send an email so they can't
trace us
dr ross i have someone who'd like to
meet you
okay
it's mr blue isn't it
mr green and he's wearing blue
isn't he
[Music]
dialysis machine will mix the antidote
to your blood so the antidote will only
take hold once we've achieved the full
reaction
just relax
okay we
are
what a nice supportive girl but i don't
think she should be in there
chris look at me
stay with me
now
do it now
she's brave because i would
run
bruce
bruce can you hear me
it's okay
you're okay you can't breathe you're on
top of him
we could get the no bell for this you
don't understand the power of this thing
it is too dangerous it cannot be
controlled they don't want the antidote
they want to make it a weapon
you would have thought he would have
gone over
this with him already
i feel like
but you're being a little paranoid don't
you think
delayed reaction
get out
that was not necessary
he was a freak accident the goal is to
do it better so banner's the only
she was just doing what you were i don't
know what you've got inside you already
the mixture could be an abomination
i didn't say
i was unwilling
i just need
informed consent
after being lifted off the ground i just
need consent
i can
fix this
[Music]
what was that
what the heck was that
hello
uh yikes you think you can control no no
not could not control it but i don't
know maybe aim it land us there no no no
keep us high
open the back door
you're gonna fall of the
surprise she's still alive
betty i've gotta try
there you go
[Music]
i like that shot that was a cool shot
hmm
[Music]
he's got such tiny ears
they are lucky that thing didn't explode
she never dies i love it
[Music]
he's like i'm tired
get out of the helicopter
what
what was that he clapped and it went
away
i mean
good for you king but like
what
[Music]
stress
get out of the helicopter you've had so
much time any last words
ugh
[Music]
get up through the heart
or decapitate him
that works too
he almost blew you up let him oh my god
[Music]
the necklace
snow steel beer
i love that he's either taking shots of
like midori or
crown apple maybe
like what a scene drink
ah
roberto sorry i need to shut up i hear
you have an unusual problem
you should talk
if i told you we were putting a team
together
who's we
[Music]
robert danny jr just like saved that
ending for me
yes
okay thoughts
so my thoughts
sorry i heard something in my house and
got a little concerned so
okay i have a lot of thoughts about this
movie so give me a second um
it was very entertaining i was
thoroughly entertained throughout the
whole movie in many different ways liv
tyler is one of my favorites like she's
such an incredible actress and i thought
she did a really great job in this movie
i loved the action i thought the action
was fun
very fun i loved the scene where um they
try to give him the the antidote like
the serum so his whole body is
convulsing and going back in between the
hulk and
himself bruce banner
i loved that sequence i thought that
sequence was super dope don't know why
she was on top of him though um that
didn't make sense to me
anyway so that was really cool i did
enjoy the fight sequence at the end i
thought that was dope like i will say
the beginning threw me off because i
felt like it was gonna be a completely
different type of movie based off like
the first 30 minutes i thought it was
sick that they like started off with the
theme of like a monster movie i was like
whoa this is like a different take than
what i was expecting like it kind of
mimicked horror movies and monster
movies in the beginning when you first
see him as the hulk that was sick i kind
of wish they would have
kept that style um and then it kind of
like like switched gears like a little
bit halfway through and then was more of
a like action like eagle eye type movie
and then it went back to like superhero
maybe it was just the tone or the style
just changed too much for me that i
couldn't it was
something about it like didn't flow as
well i feel like as iron man and stuff
but i don't know it was still
entertaining like i enjoyed watching it
um i wasn't bored so you know what i
mean first of all i'm just gonna like
talk about the ending because
i feel like a lot of times
movies are considered to be good or bad
whether or not the ending is good or bad
like the ending has a lot to do with
people's decisions on whether or not
they like the movie i feel like now i
can kind of understand why people may
not have liked this movie
i felt like it would have been more
powerful
if he did kill the other hulk i thought
the whole point of
how dangerous he was was that he
couldn't control it and he couldn't
remember people when he's in that state
and so i thought it would have been more
powerful she was like no don't and then
he just
freaking like snapped his neck off like
that would have been like whoa
because then that also would kind of
signal to her like
i love him but like he's he's still
dangerous like very dangerous i get how
sweet it was that she was able to calm
him down when he was in that state and
that he could remember her like it was
cute but there were just so many things
about this movie that i feel like didn't
make sense to me i felt like some of the
acting like i don't know if it was like
the script or if it was acting like i
don't want to you know harp on anyone in
this movie but something about it just
fell off to me like some of the dialogue
there was something missing i don't know
what it was
um i feel like edward norton did like
made a choice to be very calm and
subdued like given the character but
something about that
didn't register with me
um on screen with some like i just it
kind i feel like it kind of messed with
their chemistry a little bit and some of
the lines i don't know
it just made me laugh and like i don't
think that it was supposed to be funny i
don't know there were parts about this
that kind of reminded me of like a
student film some of the plot points and
dialogue was like kind of reminded me of
that it was different i also don't know
that much about bruce banner in general
and i think that i still have a lot of
questions after watching it like where's
mark ruffalo
anyway guys i hope you enjoyed my
reaction again please hit that subscribe
button that like button that helps the
algorithm head over to the patreon if
you want to see my full reaction i do a
lot of this
um
also
a quick shout out to my brother it is
his birthday today and his favorite
color is green and so i thought it was
really funny that it just so happened
that i was scheduled to film this today
so happy birthday kyle and look it's
green that was the other thing too so
much green
in this movie like everything was green
the fact that mr blue is wearing blue
and then he was like oh it just happened
to be wearing a green sweater like that
was funny to me so many things in this
movie was green like everything even the
dude like shooting alcohol at the bar
it was green the soda was green
everything was green even the usb drive
like lit up green and it's like it just
i don't know something about
everything being green like kept making
me like laugh a little bit
like internally um i don't know if i
like let that on when i was watching it
but it was there was a lot of
maybe that also took me out of it a few
times because like a lot of this didn't
really seem that like
obviously it's not based on reality at
all but like it was very campy it was
very campy but um
it was fun it was a fun movie i had a
fun time watching it i hope you guys did
as well and honestly robert dying junior
coming in at the end like that got me to
uh stop in my tracks and shut the f up
he brought me back you know what i mean
like this movie was a ride but he like
brought me back to like yes iron man
it's here everything's fine it made me
excited i'm excited to watch the
avengers so please hit that notification
bell again if you want to see my next
reaction and i hope you guys have a
wonderful night
hulk smash okay bye
[Music]